اليوم شهد تحليق للطيران الحربي في الجنوب
من منطقه بحري في منطقه شرق النيل تحديدا
عموما
اليوم هو اهدى من يوم البارحه البارحه كان
شهيدا عمليه
الطلعات جويه عده في منطقه بحر الكبرى
تقللتها عمليات قذائف ومدفعيه
استهدفت مناطق للدعم السريع الدعم السريع
قوات الدعم السريع تحاول ان تبعد الطائرات
باستخدام المضادات الطيران في تلك المناطق
الاجواء هنا عموما في منطقه بحري الكبرى
نوعا ما هاديه التحليق في هذه المنطقه
للطيران كان قليله قليلا مقارنه مقارنه
بيوم امس في هذه المنطقه التي نحن فيها
قبل نحو اسبوع كانت هناك معركه ومواجهه ما
بين قوات الدعم السريه
وتعزيزات عسكريه من الجيش السوداني
ادت الى التفجر ذخائر كانت في احداث
سيارات التابعه للجيش السوداني مما ادى
الى حطام وتناثر هذه الذخائر في عدد من
المناطق وادى الى تدمير هذه المنطقه كما
ترونها الان في هذه الصوره
عموما في منطقه
بحرية
في شوارعها الرئيسيه
هل كانت في عربات معينه تم استهدافها ما
قصتها
هذه الدقائق كانت في سياره التي ترونها
الان كانت تحمل عددا من الذخائر تحطمت هذه
السياره وكانت الحافله او عفوا الناقله
التي تحمل عدد كبير من الذقائر تفجر منها
ومنها ما زال لم يتفجر بعد الدعم السريع
اعلنت قبل ذلك قبل نحو اسبوع او اكثر من
اسبوع انها منعت هذا المتحرك
من الجيش من الدخول الى هذه المنطقه
والحقت به القسائر واستطاعت ان تفجر هذه
العربه النقل التي كانت تحمل عدد من
الذقائر بحسب بيانات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه عموما
ما تزال منطقه بحري هي منطقه ساخنه تتعرض
من حين الى اخر الى عمليات قصف سواء كان
مدفعي او التغيرات وهنا اتحدث عن احياء
كافوري ومنطقته الصناعات
والشرق النيل هذه المناطق كانت ساخنه خلال
الايام الماضيه لكن اليوم مقارنه بالايام
الماضيه نوعا ما كان كانت عمليات تحقيق
الطيران الحربي في هذه المنطقه قليله
وتتركز الان المعارك والمواجهات ما بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
محيط القصر وفي محيط القياده العامه
وبالتحديد في منطقه السوق العربي بواسطه